defend our American flag we're very
proud of our flag we will protect
preserve and promote the American Way of
life and we will always stand strong for
God country family and freedom I just
want to thank everybody for being here
there's a very special moment I think
especially so because you've done so
much over the last short period of time
to bring life and safety to the United
States of America and other parts of the
world by the way but to the United
States and I want to thank you god bless
you all thank you very much Admiral
thank you very much
[Music]
you
you
there are critics who can't believe you
left Hong Kong how do you respond to
them well I think well in the future I
will continue to commit myself into the
International Africa to work and well in
these past few days I've been doing a
lot of rest and stuff so for me is a
commitment actually towards the movement
and we all know that the National
Security love-related method the room of
doing so in Hong Kong and so yeah in the
future I will continue to fight for
democracy and I think people understand
that we need to have a different
position on different fronts so that we
could better utilize our own ability
the voting magic says also is very
little access light extra magic like
they're very strict on it so it's very
very good i thing is about times to have
a bit of change this what's or election
about you know need a change in their
honor
hopefully everybody hopefully everybody
hopeful goods and a future for our next
generation whatever we are not talking
in smaller be it has not seem to do it's
awesome
[Music]
dependently through which part of the
respiratory tract air passes and where
the virus is and what we do whether we
brace we speak or we see there are
different studies of aerosols generated
different concentrations of them and
then if they pass through the area of
the respiratory tract where there's
virus they also become virus on the web
so this cloud is cloud which stays
around in the air it may contain the and
if that is the case they stay suspended
in the air and they can stay suspended
in the air for quite a long time until
they are somehow removed from the air
and in places where ventilation is
inefficient insufficient they can stay
for a long very long time they could
easily stay in the air for a few hours
the dis depends on the condition of the
environment viruses is described like
cool air and dry conditions so if these
are the conditions like in many of his
buildings for example this could be good
conditions if on the other hand we go
outside where there is hot and in
addition UV radiation
well with very short period of time they
will be deactivate
well very much so but this is not the
only aspect since UV radiation it is the
very fast dilution outdoors which we say
well a large reservoir dilution is very
fast
so therefore the air or transmission
outdoors has very little chances - okay
of course there is still dead contact if
you are standing next to somebody for
long time and this person sneezes at you
or something like this that's the close
combat but other words in airborne
transmission much less like
[Music]
and the wasting reactions to by
different parties including tech
companies big tech like Facebook Twitter
and Google they've stopped giving data a
tick-tock pulled down its app from Hong
Kong so make that as an activist how
will this change the way you operate and
how you get your message across
well I'm actually not only to talk like
tech giants like Facebook and well
Twitter I understand that they have an
internal deliberation about whether it
is still safe for them to operate in
Hong Kong because they are closest in
the national security law saying that oh
if you have any in any petition make
until I assist them too well or review
or reviews - in a competent in
compliance with the order of the
government you may be punished and this
is actually a huge huge risk for a lot
of media platforms so yes indeed
it creates chilling effect not only for
those people who believe in democracy or
political activist well for now the tech
giant's they're also worrying about
their future so this is such a draconian
law that I don't I don't I don't know
whether the government preempted such a
provocative influence of that and they
are capable of handling this the freedom
of information freedom of like what
movement etc is cruel